we had a bright we had a breakfast and
for Father's Day
nice mine who ie my brother-in-law my
father not myself the whole family
follow mama Braun law they get nice
cards their family prepared them a nice
Father's Day card I look over at my wife
she's got a blank expression she's like
we have a card my daughter's I guess my
daughter I as the dinners are I get a
napkin show happy Hopkin a crinkled
matter there then I'm not exaggerating
was wet on a corner
I think it's tickets shoved at me
half-assed hideaway and just in crayon
happy Father's Day I can't read it
love Smith it was great what thanks
thanks guys put a little effort into it
both of that up and put it in my pocket
that's good can you do a motor you get
on Father's Day anyway there's nothing
and I'm fine yeah make it and they could
have done either be a man to come up a
little bit effort a little laugh
yourself laughing and daddy yeah a
little so call me daddy anyway dick suck
she get father's a dick sock yeah well
dude it's all good baby what you can
plan for their caucus my [ __ ] is epic
apparently what whoa man what you know
married sex yeah missionary don't look
me in the eye what you guys do at night
[ __ ] no you weren't
okay y'all fooling anybody at night you
you know I'll tell you what I told you
guys do you set up hotel or air B&B
uh I'm condo okay I'll tell you what is
better now for me always
you've been at four seasons shut your
mouth yeah well I'll tell you what what
I did tell you what it's been
I spent a lot of time in Hawaii doing
when I wasn't snorkeling Jack you know
me
no I I watched Jack I never wild goals I
watched parts unknown by Anthony
Bourdain Oh welcome to 2013 I knew you'd
make fun of me for this but I'm obsessed
with it and I well and I know there's no
new ones coming out yeah I want to go
WOW till we do it
so I'm just saying I you missed current
events sometimes I didn't know if
there's no new you know there's no
season about everything on oh you know
no I didn't know if you knew I'm telling
no God no Tanja I love you too okay now
because you just said something that was
not a taste no daughter no good I
understand there's no you see so it
makes look at me no listen to me do you
pick up a lynching
look at me Cheers oh why hey that didn't
help it's nothing
Jesus oh wow yeah well you know what you
know what there's hell I'm just saying
there's no new host Robin please I have
to well you brought this on yourself so
I'm gonna call back oh no man
yeah all I'm saying is they haven't
select a new host expect a call from Joe
no it's not a big deal but you'll have
to have a sit-down I'm begging you
I understand ahead time you that's it
Joe's one of my friends is like hey you
free to talk I'm like oh yeah what do
you want yeah I don't like when anybody
does it hey can I talk to you nothing
ever comes from that if a girl goes we
need to talk it's a nightmare
yeah can we talk it's name yeah sure
what happened it's always so serious I
don't like that I don't like that no
thank you
a tug of war between three I guess
they're pro wrestlers yeah oh you did
crazy yeah yeah this some people think
it's fake
I can't tell I can't lie prove it weird
is the Rope goes like yeah but they do
this often I guess they do yeah hmm
tigers lions
what people yeah but you think the
people there would be able to tell it's
fake
that's it just so it's not a huge lying
but your well you have that that see how
there's a crank in that rubles like yeah
that's legit I don't know because maybe
the Tigers just I don't know that rope
curves like that ain't legit lying
tug-of-war I'll hold that
all those guys off I think there's other
videos see there's one here too with a
bunch of kids and this is more straight
well oh that's a male lion biscuit or a
whole bunch of them
oh yes just dominating they're not doing
terrible they're doing better in the
fight so four kids and one adult and the
lion just kind of [ __ ] it around
that's raised y'all strong yeah there
and that's not that big of a line mm-hmm
I'm full-grown a 500-pound male lion
Brennan to be quiet about Lions you
don't know anything about lions
Wildlife's ago alright and I've done
this with a dog do a pit bull [ __ ]
you just like dogs I can pick a pit bull
that was like bolted on yeah that's
that's ridiculous oh no that's the bolt
to not make it back through all the way
so you don't get yeah yeah yeah it's
gonna rip your [ __ ] face off you know
what I mean like I'm going to score
crystal the Adar
are you performing anywhere live soon
well yeah like where can I see you just
go to Chris D'Elia calm okay hey calm
down man I'm a fan all right calm down
[ __ ] I'm a fan all right you're
not a fan don't be yelling at me cuz I
just want to come see your car guys take
it easy where are you gonna be soon I
just mentioned where I was okay when's
the next time you're doing comedy I just
said Oklahoma dude when Thursday okay -
why is he dude I'm a fan man
let's take it easy man kratom which is
actually an addictive drug Brendan's not
into it anymore
well don't snot he got vertigo from it
so he found out that that's the reason
why he had vertigo really yeah I saw the
fans stay away from it he said that yeah
I wonder if or at least he knows that
that's what caused it cuz he's when he
was off of it he said that's when I
disappeared whoa almost immediately wow
it's so cool to be into things every now
and then and you don't Punk Punk yeah
hey hey hey look Will's got a [ __ ]
three gallon jug no it's me you know I'm
just here to hang out don't mind me
do you interview guys when you say that
yeah okay all right but you gotta admit
we [ __ ] got you right Chris yeah I
didn't I didn't know you were coming all
right but I didn't know you're coming so
let's regroup here okay so but pretty
good you gotta admit right sure it's
pretty good I don't mean to like get in
on your no it's okay well you are
talking about a [ __ ] thing little bit
of escapism is dude I don't like to
[ __ ] talk about the ship a bride and
drink his [ __ ] bull because he's just
cuz he's a sweet tart tart and ass
that's no I know because I have survived
raw barring doctor doctor a good podcast
what are you a [ __ ] nice hey will
that water jug is too big course it is
no it's not it's so annoying
well at least you know what you do hold
it with one hand and do that
about this disrespected somebody if
somebody starts shooting at you can hide
behind it no yeah you know what dude
just how about this get one half the
size and when you're done with it
get another one no I need this one it's
got two compartments and the other
compartment holds an extra pair of
shorts [ __ ] Super Deluxe Oh kid and
the sweet two tootin tartar - that's not
true this has been a [ __ ] this is
big [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] what I mean
yeah and it's always like yeah as if
that's the pinnacle of [ __ ] you got
it snagging a white guys yeah you got
like four or five of them and Bobby Lee
fighting for that [ __ ] thing give a
shine the way just give it to him then
give it to me then give it to Michael
either way something right now I didn't
promote that [ __ ] at all I lost by
one percent if I promoted it God also
let me tell you this much if I if I ever
win that I'm making you some [ __ ]
earrings [ __ ] you don't diss put some
water mints on your [ __ ] lobes you no
disrespect that dead that's an amazing
award you don't disrespect the begin of
awards what what happened with the word
that I gave you best woman from the last
time I was here I never got asked what
did I tell you about that if I don't see
it here next time something's going up
your ass
well like the [ __ ] award at the
[ __ ] Airport they didn't have it was
an Oscar I saw that okay it said best
woman and he was offended by that yeah
because he's a piece of [ __ ] there and
so there it is
okay there it is well then we're fun
yeah so [ __ ] both you guys this is our
base has been the fighter and the kid
core strength and what are you doing -
how's this delivering it
Wow let's go do it do it well nice
that's how it should be
don't write a hold on it'll figure now
welcome it - there you go there you go
perfect
yeah over Table Talk that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that little [ __ ] well the machine the
Dinks we once we won thanks guys thank
you guys I appreciate fresh fish
appreciate you got appreciate